j'ai envie entendent dan dans ton
analyse d'abord une militante vegan qui
est avec nous comme je voulais dit et
pour vous c'est simple et france et son
respect ce responsable de milliers de
meurtres chaque jour en mangeant de la
viande
exact alors qu'est ce que vous avez à
dire à notre boucher qui est là alors je
suis une danseuse d'alert je viens
montrer et dire ce que vous ne voulez
pas montré vous médias collabos avait
refusé de montrer le bébé assassiné dans
les bras d'un militant sur ce même la
tombe de l'udm 18,2 quête de quoi vous
les parties que sont la dde poche oh oui
le petit cochon on vient de le voir vous
avez refusé de le montrer dans le
moniteur non non non non on l'a vu il
était le n 18
non mais on n'y a eu qu'un petit cochon
n'est qu'un petit coup chanson le
plateau mais je vous dis il a été montré
alors comme les images que je vais dire
pourquoi le montrera parce qu'il ya des
règles en télévision exacte est on est
en direct donc on l'a montré au début et
vous savez on peut pas montrer comme ça
des animaux morts il ya des enfants qui
nous regardent il ya déjà des parents
aussi yade et on essaie d image un peu
choquant et on ne peut pas montrer
toutes les images il ya une csa
christine kelly aucun des partis et je
pense c'est une image et qu'on peut pas
montrer qu'il me rappelle très bien de
ce moment là on l'a on a dit qu'on ne
faisait pas de gros plans parce que ça
avait surpris tout le monde c'était un
un coup journaleux robin veut dire alors
alyzia 10
ce qui est choquant c'est surtout
vitrine bon c'est quoi ce qui ce qui est
rien les vitrines pousse à la résistance
animalistes avons fait une promesse à ce
petit porcelet qui ne seraient pas morts
pour rien balances ton post n'est ce pas
alors oui balancer maintenant votre
poste l'acte neufs commence maintenant
plus jamais les ports ne seront balancés
action directe de justice maintenant sur
boucherie absolution alors là vous êtes
en morceau crack teneur
[Applaudissements]
j'ai rien contre vous et je comprends
tout ça est votre constat mais juste
anaïs là on a l'impression que vous
donnez des codes direct la sélection
entendu cautionner elle est passionnée
elle est très émue je sais écouter la ce
qu'elle dit est important mais pour une
boîte toujours d'accord avec tout ce
qu'elle j'ai gardées secrètes et un mort
c'est un peu paradoxal pas alors comme
ça
anaïs hadji nom m'a dit plus que votre
écoute notre message est important mais
anna bree en droit que les
téléspectateurs le comprennent ne visait
pas analyse par les libres maintenant
mais vous êtes le message le message est
très très claire lise le message est
très très clair à nos élus action tout
le direct maintenant aux actions
illégales sur boucherie absolution
maintenant absolution maintenant sur le
facebook du free abolition actions
illégales insurrection maintenant